it was a thursday
june the 23rd
collect your belongings you are free to
go
when escorted outside go directly to
your car
do not talk to reporters
my head is spinning my heart is racing i
can't get a breath
i just want out of there
when i get to my car
i throw everything on the back
and i just collapse into the driver's
seat
i can't do this
i can't go home
to my family
that i haven't seen
in a week
and pretend to be happy
not even their love
and support could help me at this
particular time
we had just sentenced a man to death
now what
just go home and wash dishes
you see
in mississippi
the death penalty is like a part of our
unspoken culture
the basic logic is if you murder someone
then you're going to receive the death
penalty
so
when the jury selection process took
place
they asked me
could you
if
the evidence presented
justified the death penalty
could you deliver
rationally and without reservations a
penalty of death
my answer was an astounding yes
and i was selected as juror number two
the trial started
from the evidence being presented
and from the pictures of the victim
my first response was yes this man is a
monster
and he deserves the death penalty
for days
i sat and looked at his hands the ones
that yielded the knife
and his pasty uh well against his pasty
white skin
his eyes
well he spent endless days in his cell
no sunlight
so his eyes were as black as his hair
and his mustache
he was very intimidating
and there was absolutely
no doubt in his guilt
but regardless of his guilt
as the days passed
i began to see this monster
as a human being
something inside of me was changing that
i just
didn't understand
i was beginning to question myself as to
whether or not i wanted to give this man
the death penalty
jury deliberations began
and the judge
gave us jury instructions
and it was to be used as a tool
in how to reach a verdict
well using this two
only led to one decision
and that was the death penalty
i felt backed into a corner
my head and my heart were in conflict
with each other
and the thought of the death penalty
made me sick
however
following the judge's instructions
being a law-abiding person
i gave up
i gave up and voted along with other 11
jurors
and there it was
our broken judicial system at work
so here i am in my car
and i'm wondering
how is my life ever going to be the same
my life was kids work
church ball games
just your average
normal everyday life
now everything felt trivial
i was going down this rabbit hole
the anger
the anxiety
the guilt
the depression
it just clung to
me i knew that i my life had to resume
so i sought counseling
the counselor diagnosed me with ptsd
and told me
that the best way to overcome the ptsd
was to talk about the trauma
however if i talked about or tried to
talk about the trauma
outside her office i was shut down
no one wanted to hear about it
he was just a murderer
get over it
it was then that i decided to become a
silent survivor
twelve years later 2006
i learned that bobby wilcher had dropped
all of his appeals
and his execution date
was approaching
that was like a punch in the stomach
all of those buried feelings just
started coming back
to try and find peace i called bobby's
attorney and i said
can i see bobby before he's executed
driving to the penitentiary on the day
of his execution
in my mind
bobby was going to be manic
but
surprisingly he was very calm
and for two hours he and i sit there and
talked about life
and i got to ask him to forgive me for
my hand in his death
his words to me were
you don't have to apologize
you didn't put me here
i did this myself
but if it'll make you feel better i
forgive you
on my way home
i stopped by a restaurant
and bought a margarita
i don't think i could get one big enough
but
to try and calm down
my phone rang
it was bobby's attorney
within two minutes of his execution they
had given him a stay
this day
gave me time
to reach out to bobby
and as crazy as it may sound we became
friends
three months later
he was executed by the state of
mississippi
i'm here
to tell you
my story
because it was precisely 22 years
later
that i even wanted to open up enough to
talk about it
when a friend encouraged me to hate
perhaps you need to talk to the other
jurors you've been through the same
experience
uncertain of what i was after
i did need to talk to them
so i set out on my quest
and i actually found most of them
the first juror i met
thought that bobby got what he deserved
another juror
well they just kind of regretted that it
took so long to carry the sentence out
then one juror i don't know what was
wrong with him but he didn't remember
anything about the trial
well
i'm thinking in my mind geez is this the
response i'm gonna get from everybody
else
well
thank god for alan
allen was a gentle soul
and when i talked to him he was
genuinely upset
about our decision
and he told me
about the day that the devastation
really set in on him and hit him
he was listening to the radio
and the radio
they were had a list of names of men to
be executed at parchman penitentiary
he heard bobby's name
and he then truly realized what he had
done and he said you know
i had a responsibility in that man's
death
now here it is 20 something years later
and alan is still dealing with that
issue
and he's never told anyone about it not
even his wife
he also told me that if the state of
mississippi wanted to keep the death
penalty
then hey they needed to
provide
counseling for the jurors
then the next juror i met was jane
jane is now totally against the death
penalty
and there was bill
bill said he had this crushing
depression for weeks
and when he went back to work
his colleagues would say things to him
like hey did you firm
to them it was just a joke
then there was john
john said his decision
weighed on him
and it burdened him daily
the final juror that i spoke to was ken
ken was the foreman of the jury
when we sat down to talk
it was apparent that he was deeply
saddened by what we were required to do
he relived the day
that he left the courthouse
and he drove home
and he went to put his key in his door
and unlock it and he said he literally
broke down
he said he knew that bobby was guilty
but the decision he made he did not
know if it was the right decision
and he said that he played it over and
over in his head
did we do the right thing
all those years
and i finally realized that i was not
the only disillusioned juror
and we talked about
sharing our experience
with potential jurors
to give them some insight into what to
expect
and to tell them do not be complacent
to know what you believe
to know where you stand and be prepared
because you don't want to walk in
one morning
as a juror
and leave at the end of the trial
feeling like a murderer
now through this storm of my life i did
find some inspiration
and it came in the form of my
granddaughters
my 14 year old granddaughter maddie
was writing an essay on the death
penalty for school
and she was asking me questions
well it dawned on me that this child was
being raised in the same
eye for an eye culture
as i was
or had been
and so i explained my experience to her
this way
that i had
sent someone to death
as i served on a jury and i asked her
did that make me a murderer
she couldn't answer
i knew then
that this topic needed to be open for
discussion and guess what happened
i got invited to speak just recently
in an abolitionist community
while i was there i got a t-shirt
and it said stop executions
well when i get home my 16 year old
granddaughter was there anna
and she says can i have that shirt
well i looked at her dad
her dad is my son
and i knew that he is still dealing with
this death penalty issue
so i turned around and i looked at her
and i said are you gonna wear this
so she turned and she looked at her dad
and she said
dad
i know how you feel
but i don't believe in the death penalty
my son
looked at me
shook his head and said
thanks mom
and i knew it wasn't a nice thanks mom
so
i learned that life had taught me some
lessons
it taught me
if i had not served on that jury
that i would still be of the same
mindset
it also gave me confidence to be able to
see through the eyes of my
granddaughters
that this younger generation
they're capable
and they're willing
to tackle these difficult
social issues
and because of my experience
my granddaughters
they're now
more equipped
to stand on their own and to think for
themselves than
to rely on cultural beliefs
so
being from a conservative christian
family
from a very conservative state in the
united states
i am here to tell you that
the death penalty has
new opponents
thank you
[Music]